[Music]
well welcome back everyone to the data
science hangout if you're joining for
the first time it's great to meet you
i'm rachel i'm the host
as i mentioned last week
it's really nice to be able to share
some space with everyone right now
so we do want to reiterate and share
again some of the avenues to help those
that are affected by the war in ukraine
that have been shared by viola and sup
but also ask others to share in the chat
as well
thank you everyone
if this is your first hangout this is an
open space for the whole data science
community to connect and chat about data
science leadership
questions you're facing
and what's going on in the world of data
science
so we want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
there's three ways to ask questions
probably more
you can jump in live
and raise your hand on zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to put a star next to it
if you want me to read it out loud if
it's maybe loud where you are or
something like that
but we also have a slido link where you
can ask questions anonymously
and our team will share that in the chat
in just a second here
just like to reiterate that we love to
hear from everyone no matter your level
of experience or area of work too
but with all of that i'm so happy to be
joined by my co-host for today kirsty
angel christie is a senior data
scientist interview coach and data
science mentor
at what says on the website grubhub and
zach already stole it from me but
congratulations are in order for your
new role now at stitchfix so chrissy i'd
love to have you introduce yourself and
maybe share a little bit about your role
sure thanks for that rachel uh so
yes i'll be joining um i'll be joining
stitchfix uh on their ab experimentation
platform team
um i probably shouldn't preface that
with a b because i'm assuming it does a
little bit more than just a b testing
but
uh i don't quite know yet so we'll see
tbd but as you might imagine my
background is specialized in
experimentation
uh data science and inference causal
inference
um
i started
in experimentation back in 2016 right
after i graduated with my master's in
statistics
um i started at groupon and at the time
web-based experimentation um
was not a
it's not what it was today i'll tell you
that i remember right before i
interviewed for my first job i would i
googled uh
you know
optimize experimentation web
experimentation and found very little
information and now it's everywhere so
um
i feel like i kind of lucked into a
little niche
that said
um on the in my free time um there are
several several other things that i do
to contribute to the data science
community
one of those things is that i am a data
science mentor through a
boot camp called thinkful
um this boot camp
i mentor data scientists and data
analysts
we um
the thing that's unique about this
particular program is that we pair
students
with mentors in addition to their
full-time or part-time curriculum that
they choose
so they really get to work with somebody
in industry understand how data science
is actually applied
uh and how that's different than a
classroom environment and then the other
thing that i've been a little bit more
focused on recently is
interview coaching
for that same student population so i
primarily work with data analysts and
data science graduates from boot camp
programs
and i conduct mock interviews with them
because a lot of these
these students and candidates
are fresh out of of this boot camp they
might be career pivoters they could be
phd students who are looking to bridge
some skills gaps they might also be um
you know
just
right out of undergrad or maybe they
didn't go to uh college at all i
actually had a student recently who
uh was in the military and then he came
out and did did um a boot camp and so
there are just a lot of different needs
but i would say there's also a lot of
anxiety around the mystery of what
comprises a technical interview
and so um
i think one of my favorite parts is just
getting people to a place where they're
feeling
confident
in their interviewing ability and that
is a lot of um
it's a lot of just recognizing that
anxiety that's there
um so yeah in a nutshell
so thanks kirsty while we're waiting for
questions to come in from everyone i'd
love to learn a little bit more about
that and maybe some of the
tips that you share with people when
you're coaching them for interviews or
how you help them get over that anxiety
excuse me um absolutely
so um
you know i think
one of the first things that i always
like to do is just kind of put out my
feelers
um and
the way that i do that is i just
i come right out and say you know if
you're anything like me
i am a nervous interviewer you know like
i just i just put it right out on the
table and make it okay
to fess up and say me too
uh that way we can just kind of
talk about the elephant in the room
and and bring the level down a little
bit um
i also think that uh
my interview style is
it
it matches the interview style that i
like to to be interviewed with
which is conversational um it's
collaborative
and um you know i'm not gonna
ask questions like you know guess what
number i'm thinking
uh you know
i do want to understand your thought
process but
if you get stuck um
i don't want to watch this i'm not going
to leave you to struggle i'm going to
nudge you forward and and and really it
doesn't take a lot but um
i think realizing that
that's all it is for people uh
is really really helpful because i think
they get caught up in this data science
um
universe where it's like well they could
ask me anything
they could but they're probably going to
focus on the job description in your
resume so let's narrow the focus
and just bring bring it down a little
bit
do people do that then when they get to
their interview
i have seen i have seen a lot of success
i really really have i um i offer all of
all of the students that i interview
to connect with me on linkedin
um and keep me posted some do some don't
and that's okay
um i love seeing my success stories uh
there was a candidate that um came in to
me
a couple months ago
and i had to escalate actually because
um i got about 15 minutes into this mock
interview
and i realized that this person was
going through some some real trauma you
know he had signaled a couple of times
like
you know um i've been i've been
working so hard for so long you know or
you know i've just been struggling for
so long
and
um it really struck a chord with me
because
i i also come from a background where i
kind of had to bootstrap myself up a bit
i was a waitress for 20 years while i
put myself through school um
i'm the first person in my family to
graduate from high school
um there are some days where you know on
my path it was really really hard and so
when he said that it just connected with
me
and i put my interview notes away and i
was like this is a different
conversation that we have to have
and so you know
we talked about it and he had this i
didn't want to call it imposter syndrome
because i think it's more than that
but it
turned out he didn't have a college
degree
and he had military experience
and
he was
afraid that
by submitting his application and
getting through an uh applicant tracking
system that he was automatically going
to be bounced away
and i said that's fine
that might be true
but that's not work what we're gonna do
because that's not how you're going to
get a job
you know and we talked about it and i
spent i was supposed to spend an hour on
the phone with this kid
i spent an hour and a half talking him
through it and i said i think about
halfway through i'm like you've got
yourself a mentor like i'm just married
to this right now but
two weeks later he got a job he just
needed a confidence boost
with other people they need to work on
some sql skills you know but being able
to identify those weaknesses early on
really sets them up for success in a
good way
that's amazing
it brings up a point i know we had
talked about earlier as well
like when people don't have degrees and
they're kind of hitting that roadblock
in
recruiting and not getting through to
the hiring manager
what can we all do
to change that
that's interesting because um
i did have another student
she
is one of the most tenacious hardest
workers
committed learners i mean she would run
laps around me i was so
amazed at her
tenacity
and
she was going to i mean she was going to
grace hopper she was going to all the
conferences talking to as many people as
she could talk to
doing everything right
but she had a political science degree
and
um
i think you know she was pie-eyed and
talking to a lot of big tech companies
um not really realizing there were other
other avenues
but um
she was getting shot down automatically
by a lot of companies because they were
saying that she didn't have a stem
degree
and i was really frustrated like part of
me was like i want to find out who those
recruiters are because i thought the
same company said that we don't need
degrees anymore
and so i feel like there's this like
know a misalignment of
well
what are what what what what do we want
from our data scientists and also i
think there's
sincerely a knowledge gap um in in some
recruiting teams that we can help with
too
um and
that's something that i i always try to
do because i end up going to all the
college recruiting
events that i can but um just educating
your recruiters on what different
flavors of data science look like and
where they might come from
i absolutely love what's happening in
the chat right now everybody's sharing
their majors as well
yeah no social science i love working
with social science teachers i was i was
a stats grad student but
um
i i i have a lot of
uh sociology phd envy i'll admit that
does anybody have experience with like
working directly with the recruiting
team at your company to kind of say
like hey this is something we might want
to look past here and change the way
we're doing it
the the company i work for state space
labs is
i think unusual um the founder himself
is the first person in his family to
have a college degree
you know bounced through several
community colleges
uh
you know ended up with a phd in
neuroscience um
so
you know this is coming from the top
down as you can imagine
so the idea of what degree you have is
pretty much
irrelevant at the company
um
you know whether it's somebody who's
being hired for engineering or data
science or anything
we have plenty of people with military
backgrounds
uh there are people with high school
degrees who work at the company but i i
fully understand that this is really
really unusual and
uh you know i think we're lucky that we
have the ceo that we have and i'm not
i'm not sure how
you convince
people
that
you know it's really not just okay to
look past the degree but probably a
really good idea
in many cases that you need
diversity
of thought and background in order to
especially
if
your company has a consumer-facing
product and you want
uh
the company as a whole to have empathy
for end users i think it's it's really
important to have
um
a really varied set of of
life experience backgrounds but yeah i'm
not i'm not really sure how you convince
people at a more traditional company
that that it's a good idea
that's awesome that your company does
that though jenny i love that yeah
does anyone else have thoughts on on
this topic oh i see matthias you have
your hand raised you want to jump in
yeah so we
we're a small start-up in the women's
health space and
we
kind of look beyond degrees in a lot of
ways a lot of our
more senior data science people
have like a biology degree or something
like that right and it's really more
about what they've done in their
previous jobs because we need them to be
effective from day one but for the more
junior folks it's kind of difficult
right so what we find is a lot of people
with degrees
even if they have a degree they're not
very good right but um
when you're more junior and then on top
of that you don't have a degree we just
don't find a lot of talent right we
don't find a lot of people that are very
good with that right it's not like we
would be opposed to that
but
the degree and the experience gives you
a little bit of a of a certification
right it's a little bit easier to say
like okay these are the people that we
should talk to because you know in a
startup there's always more to do than
you have time right so if you if you go
really in depth with like five
candidates or ten candidates that's a
lot of drain on the organization right
so you're trying to use these degrees as
a little bit of a of a filter to see who
we can talk to quickly
i think that's a good call out in the
startup space in particular
it's a little bit
different of a situation because
like you said you need people who can be
effective from from day one hit the
ground running
um you know and and and in that case
maybe that's where interns come in uh at
a certain maturity uh once you get there
but um
but
you know it's definitely one of those
things where you know
when you can take on uh a
junior
level person i mean
we we still have to hire junior level
people because we're all going to get
older
it's just not a sustainable model if we
don't um and so i love seeing certain
organizations that do that intentionally
think about like the bandwidth that they
have to be able to train in-house and
um
companies
launched programs successfully to do
that
i see there's a few other hands raised
too mike do you want to jump in
yeah i think um i wanted to ask christy
about well first if i can make a
a comment and then ask a question
comment is you you clearly are helping
candidates and kind of training them how
to do interviews are you also training
interviewers
because you know i think a lot of
interviewers could do with a bit of
skills
i agree with that 100
um so when i was at groupon um my job
before
my last job gov hub that was something
that i was involved in
um towards the end i was working we had
um similar to amazon we had what we
called a bar raiser program
and so um
one of the things that i wanted to see
happen
um i helped to
ensure that
that all
interview loops had a diverse
representation from the interviewers
that was something that was happening
at a certain level above or above at one
point um or on my team because i would
track down the recruiter and insist on
it um but the other thing
uh that we were working on is extending
the bar raiser training program
more um more broadly
to like some of those core principles
and tenants to
all interviewers
because um
interviewing's hard you know i mean i i
think i got thrown into it when i first
started doing it
um
so i i always interview from the
perspective of kind of an interviewee is
you know how how do i want to be treated
and it i think that makes it hard for me
it's one of those things that i still to
this day second guess is
um
[Music]
that external validity it's like
was it was it me or was it was it my
question or was it the candidate and
that's not a good place to be in because
this is someone's livelihood that you're
that you're handling and i take that
very seriously so i think that you're
right um we all need to learn to become
better interviewers it's
um
i think that
we make these really complicated
frameworks for interviewing
um
when really you know if we just had some
uh that's what we're looking for
thoughtful and meaningful conversations
with people
about what they've done and what they
know and how they think about things
and we might get further
it'd be really nice to to hear you know
what are the kind of conversation
starter questions or
you know things that
because as an interviewer you want to
get a feel for whether that person has
skill or even just personality to to
deal with the job you're interviewing
for
you know what are good starter questions
that you know open them up to kind of go
right you know
give me the information but let's do it
in a way that isn't challenging or
you know
difficult if you know what i mean i mean
it's supposed to be a little difficult
but it's more as you say it's a kind of
you know come on just just tell
me so yeah i mean the first thing you
want to do is you want to try to put
them at ease and develop some trust
really quickly
and i wish i could explain to you how to
do that but i was a waitress for 20
years and so
that's that's literally the job
is you know hi table how are you and in
three seconds i have to assess
are you hungry grouchy happy like you
know whatever what kind of mood are you
in uh you know and read the room
so um
i don't i don't know how it practice
uh trial and error making mistakes
yeah
i've heard that before in interviews
it's like was i just really drained and
being awkward at starting conversation
or
was it just that we weren't weren't
connecting
yeah like i think it was maybe it was me
but
almost i'm so glad that we have like
panels though because then you can kind
of corroborate the evidence and
yeah
definitely
zach i see you have your hand raised too
do you want to jump in yeah i was just
coming from some that's as i said i
don't go to university in the uk i
believe mike is also from the uk uh
we have something called apprenticeship
so you do four days working one day
learning
but the qualification isn't seen in the
same way it's basically
i
from you basically just get 18 months
two years of experience and that's how
you sell yourself rather than the
qualification
uh
but
i
i hope coming from some that as i said i
know that i've from the position i put
myself in i don't want to go to
university so i know i have to work
harder
what if so
i deal with these external stuff
i end competitions and all that stuff
um
like build shiny dashboards models
but yeah it's the it's the instant
rejection and all this which i
but like sounds like i completely
understand it if they're getting
100 or so applicants
or 200 no one's going to be able to go
through that they have to have a minimum
requirement
or
yeah as
uh
as matteo said it's just gonna spend
someone's gonna spend their entire week
looking at one job or two weeks
depending on how big it is so i
completely understand it though
which is why
i've started looking at smaller
companies because they're more likely to
take a chance take a risk uh have less
applicants so what someone's going to be
able to spend looking at it and then
hopefully once they go actually this
person's got an interesting
portfolio
and get myself into that so that's what
i've been looking i've only been looking
for about two weeks now so it's not like
i'm expecting lots but yeah that's the
way that i'm approaching i'm sure other
people have got
uh other ways that they're looking at it
so
yeah just someone as someone that's in
this for a different perspective
yeah that's great perspective zach and
great that you're doing all those
contests and stuff too like big data
bowl i know we mentioned but
um javier i see you had your hand raised
too is
do you have uh something to weigh in on
this topic
yeah i i
i kind of had a question for christy
just to follow up to all these
discussions um because i've experienced
this myself
two occasions in my career in my life
um
years back i was super unhappy in a job
and
you know i was so
busy with that job
that
finding interviews or getting interviews
applying for jobs felt exhausting
and
kind of like a parallel to this
i
eventually quit that job and went back
to grad school because i was like okay
i'm not getting the types of jobs i want
you know i was
reading and learning all about
predictive modeling without even really
knowing what it was i was just very
interested in the way people were
presenting on this topic
so i went back to grad school and i
experienced like
significant
interview fatigue i mean the first month
or two were very exciting you know
you're applying to positions
um but after a while it's it becomes
sort of taxing because you're like okay
i have to sound excited about this job
like it no longer becomes fun on a
regular basis to interview and learn
about these companies
do you have i don't know what the right
answer is like i've thought about this a
lot but do you have any guidance for
people that are you know students who
are kind of feeling this fatigue or just
people unhappy in their current job or
or you know like zach not to put you on
the spot but someone like zach trying to
break into the into the space and
applying
you know position after position
yeah
um i mean i'll tackle the the breaking
into the space piece uh first because i
think it's it's sort of a a slightly
different problem
um
i i recommend to all of uh my mentees
um like like i mentioned um the fellow
who didn't have a college degree either
when i said we're not gonna go through
applicant tracking systems what i meant
was we're going to
network and i don't like the word
networking because i think it
automatically puts people up kind of
like oh i don't want to do that but
utilize linkedin as a social media a
professional social media site
um you know find people who are
generating content that you find uh
compelling and interesting
um you know find your tribe
uh once you find your tribe you know or
as you begin finding your tribe engage
they're going to start knowing who you
are by your comments and your feedback
and your ideas that you're contributing
and then believe it or not
you're going to start building a
reputation for yourself
i mean it's just how human relationships
work uh you don't mean to be doing it
but you just being you that's what
happens um that's how i got my job at
stitch fix honestly uh i had followed my
my new boss eric weber on linkedin for
some time um i really align with his
style of leadership when i think about
the kind of leader that i want to be
um i want to be
like eric um and so
uh we we stayed connected um now i'll
i'll
address
uh the other question that you had
javier which was you know the interview
fatigue
and i can speak to this personally uh
because i was laid off in 2020 due to
covid in april um in fact i had the
great fortune of graduating in 2010
during the housing market crash
not knowing what i wanted to do and then
yeah anyways um
interview fatigue i interviewed for
seven months in 2020
uh i was planning to uh leave groupon
and move on to my next journey or the
next step in my journey
um you know i think i had already been
planning that at the beginning of 2020
and then once i started applying and
covid started the rug just got pulled
out from underneath me because the
entire market changed uh where i thought
i had a leg up all of a sudden got very
very competitive and then also what was
happening behind the scenes that made it
incredibly frustrating
was that different um positions were
being combined or pulled because
nobody knew where the pandemic was going
to go
so
talk about frustration
i made it
all the way through full rounds with
pinterest twice
and i think five times with facebook in
a matter of a couple months
so um
i get fatigue but i think
personally what i can say is when i
finally
felt the most successful um or the most
at ease
um
was when i just gave into it you know
it's like
okay i've done all the hard work i've
prepared all i can prepare
um you know
[Music]
now i just
like i just have to show up and and be
the most authentic me that i can be like
i just need to bring her along for the
ride because if she shows up
then i'm good
but that's that's where the problem
comes it's like can i
is she gonna come today you know so i
think it's just making sure that you're
taking care of yourself
enough so that you can be there i think
the other thing is just being really
candid and honest with your recruiting
partners
i think people forget that they are your
partners
um and so
always advocate for yourself with your
recruiters
if you wake up
on the day of your interview and like
you're in a panic attack or you know
like
any number of things that could happen
these days right
don't there's no shame in rescheduling
they want your best self to show up too
they want you to get the job they don't
want to continue continue interviewing
forever they have work that they want to
do and they want you to come along and
do the work too
so um just i think
for me that was that was what really
unlocked progress for me and and it
helped um
it helped
bring joy back into it because it helped
me connect with my why
that's great chrissy i can see in the
chat too it's resonating with a lot of
people and i i love i can't read the
chat right now but i love seeing you all
talking to each other
um i want to make sure to get to some of
the anonymous questions that were asked
too and this is actually a follow-up
to the question now
but how do you stay motivated and
optimistic
while looking for a job after like a
certain number of rejections or ghosting
from a company
first thing i do
um
there's there's a couple of things the
first thing i do is um i allow myself a
day to grieve
and just feel the way i'm gonna feel um
like i've i i've seen people
um
[Music]
who can knock out interviews back to
back you know and even you've seen
people do two final rounds in one day
that's not me um i mean i'm resilient
but like i also need my space to just
to work through my feelings um so if
that's you that's okay
um
i have a dog who looks like a muppet he
helps a lot
uh he gets me out of my head when i just
want to like curl up in bed i still
gotta take care of him
um
so that helps and he's just goofy and he
makes me laugh um
so that's nice
um
yeah i i gotta be honest like you really
gotta hunt for positivity these days
but um where you can find it take it
and just kind of relish in it for a
little bit
definitely
i see matthias you're smiling and
raising your hand too
i just i just think that that's uh such
good advice right and i think one thing
um probably also to always keep in mind
uh the people on the other end the
people who hire you are human right so
um a there there's a lot of people who
are also and i'm sorry to
say this over and over again there's a
lot of people who are not good at their
jobs right so if they don't hire you
there's a lot of people who
you know don't do the diligence they
don't put the work in to find the best
candidates so it's not you right i think
that's always important to keep in mind
and then when you do work with good
people and they don't hire you
and
that's also not a bad thing because if
they know what they're doing
then they know that you're not a good
fit that doesn't say anything about you
as a person that just means hey in this
position our assessment is you might not
be as successful as you want to be so
you know take that i know this is like
super
hard to take it as that but that is also
a positive trust them right so if you
work with good people trust their
judgment if you work with bad people
just
brush it off it doesn't matter move on
to the next thing get your feet in the
door once you have the foot in the door
do the best thing you can and build your
expertise that's at least from from
the other side from the side that
highest
i don't know if that matters or not
and i would add to that you know like
it can be hard to take the ominous like
not a good fit because it's it's vague
and it's like well
i thought it was a great fit you know
it's not specific um
but if you can imagine um some realistic
scenarios for example like
i mean i've had not a good fit right now
um and and when companies are able to
give that kind of feedback where
um
well for example i'll give an example uh
i interviewed with
netflix in 2020
is one of the first interviews that i
did because in my mind i'm like
not going to get that job uh and so i
figured it would be a practice interview
right
um well first of all
it still feels crappy when netflix even
if you don't think you're gonna get the
job when netflix tells you no you're
still like
well if i can't get the job i don't want
how am i gonna get the job i do want you
know and so
it is a constant mind game and
it's a mind game that you have to
outsmart yourself at really
um
but i think the other thing is
uh
what helped me so much in this this
interview round where um that i just
went through
that same recruiter reached back out to
me
now a year and a half later
um
they remember you and apparently what i
didn't know at the time was and this is
so funny to me apparently i nailed the
statistics round which i think was the
one that i thought i did the the least
uh well in and
it just wasn't as efficient in sequel
and it's like well i mean
yeah okay i mean i can i can practice
sql drills more but that was it
so um that felt great to know that like
i was that close and
getting that feedback helps because
you're like okay
i'm not far off i am on the right path
people do like you know what i have to
contribute but they just don't need me
right now or they need something
slightly different
yeah and if you work with a good company
they are always happy to give you that
feedback right if you ask right
no one likes to have that conversation
unprompted but if you if you ask them
like hey what was it um they will always
have constructive feedback there yeah
christy robert and i were talking a
little bit earlier on slack about um
like red flags to look out for when
you're interviewing with a company
um
and
i think right now like we see a lot of
recruiter emails from people maybe
promises huge salaries or
like how do you decide which opportunity
to take or to interview for out of some
of the others
yeah um
okay hang on let me just jot this down
because i i wanna those are i think two
really good um questions i wanna address
separately so
red flags and then there was um
i'm sorry what was the second question
um how did you decide
which opportunity
to go after or to take yeah okay
so um first let's start with red flags
um
for me
it depends on like what your values are
right uh for me
personally things that i value in a
position
um are
uh you know
immediately having that feeling where it
can be my authentic self that like i
feel that natural ease of communication
um maybe sense of humor some laughter
um i want to know that like we can work
together
and i i like to work in a fun
environment i like to bring a sense of
humor um and so
just making sure that like we're on the
same page there because
uh
like this is what you get like what you
see is what you get with me and i'm very
upset about that so
um so i i'm particular
um
i
i value
uh people with diverse backgrounds
um you know so a diverse team i i value
um
i value learning i value
building for the long term um i value
innovation i value you know so i think
about my values and i'm trying to find
a team that fits with that um
and i i like i knew a lot about eric
going in so that one was a no-brainer
for me um in fact like i approached him
because i i wanted to work with him
before
um
so i try to shop for managers
if i'm honest if i can
i will always shop for a manager um and
if i feel like i'm not like connecting a
culture like on the same page
in terms of culture
that's where all my questions are gonna
go if i don't get a sense of that from
them immediately i'm going to ask about
it and my favorite questions is just can
you describe your team culture
um
unsurprisingly
the same person who introduced
themselves as a princeton ph.d
struggled to define their team culture
so
you know to me that was a red flag
i'm trying to think of other like i look
for managers who really care about
growing their team members
um i think some managers forget that's
part of their job
um
and that's okay you know because
managers also
are new managers sometimes um you know
and maybe you're not supported the way
that they need to be supported but
um
[Music]
those are those are the things that i
look for and if i'm not getting a vibe
that that's there i'm i'm gonna keep
moving
[Music]
what factors
so those are some of the factors that
drove my decision
early on my job search i was really torn
because i was unsatisfied where i was um
for no reason other than just like
personally i think logistics is kind of
boring it's like a bunch of time stamps
and
uh it doesn't i want to see um like more
direct impact on people um and to me
uh as someone who's worked on
experimentation platforms uh the people
i impact are are my colleagues my
stakeholders so i have a special place
in my heart for
internal tooling um
[Music]
and i think i i
for a long time i grappled with that
point because
i felt like i wasn't a whole data
scientist because i had never
done
more algorithmic data science or machine
learning i've never put a model into
production
um
[Music]
but my last project that my last role
was putting together an experimentation
training program
and
i got to write and i got to teach
and i got to just like brain dump all of
the things that i know about
experimentation
and i think simultaneously i've been
really struggling with trying to
understand what confidence is like
at the core what is confidence
and when i was observing myself just
fluidly explaining what experimentation
is and how to do it to non-technical
people
in a very like plain and simple way i
was like wait a minute
this is confidence i mean i'm being
confident right now and so um
i just realized like
this is this is what i know how to do
well
and
i'm at the point in my life you know
i'm not
i don't have enough time to be an expert
in everything um and so
maybe i just be an expert in testing and
i can collect more hobbies and do fun
stuff on the side and enjoy life
i love that
finding finding the area that you're
confident in yeah
yeah
there's quite a few anonymous questions
too i don't want to to miss let me just
jump over sorry i was like going back
and forth
um someone had said
i have been working as a data scientist
for three plus years now but i'm feeling
my experience doesn't look valuable to
recruit recruiters just assuming from
low calls
do you have any suggestions
yeah um
[Music]
so
when i
so i kind of approached this problem as
a data scientist and i and i think you
know
if you are if you're blind or if you're
just kind of cold applying
you know
through company websites
um you know then you want to target the
top of the funnel maybe take a take a
look at your resume
um maybe maybe see if
you can get some resume reviews from
colleagues or peers that you trust um
and see
um see what their thoughts are uh if
there's a way that maybe that might be
more effective
but again i i still think that if you
can get um referrals
or
um
or you're like i said your resume into
the hands of a hiring manager
um there's lots of hiring managers on
linkedin right now that are blatantly
advertising for roles that they're
trying to fill so take advantage of that
um
but if it's not a resume problem um you
know and it really is just a matter of
of
uh thin content
um you know there's a lot of different
ways that you can fill that out
so
um
let me think here i mean there's
definitely projects that you can do on
your own
um there are volunteer organizations
where you can
join as part of a team
to do
um do projects
um i know data science for social good
has an offshoot but i can't remember
the name of it um maybe we can look that
up later and share that out
but look for volunteer opportunities um
because then you have the
good fortune of learning from other
people as well
um
i think going to meetups um particularly
the python and our meetups if you can
another really great way to network and
form community but um
you know you just try to build
communities of people um who are willing
to to vouch for you and and pass your
resume along
because that's that's the best way
um
[Music]
yeah i think and then like in the
situation that you're in
um
if you have any say about the projects
that you're working on
try to be strategic um
see if there's other projects that you
think are valuable that someone's
working on see if you can ask your
manager
um if you can be a part of that um in a
small way
definitely that's great chrissy and i i
can't speak for everybody here on the
call but i i love the community feel of
this too and i'm sure there's a bunch of
people on this call right now who'd be
willing to like take a look at your
resume as well and connect with you
but i do want to say if anybody is in
that
position right now
feel free to shoot me an email too and
i'll try and help you connect with
people as well people reach out all the
time on linkedin that are on
the other side too they're hiring for
roles and they just can't find people
and there just seems to be this mismatch
happening
but yeah definitely feel free to reach
out to or
if anyone wants to put in the chat if
you're willing to connect with someone
too
israel i know you had a somewhat similar
question too so i just wanted to see if
you had any other
follow-up to add to uh
kind of my question was uh like for data
science roles i see a lot of
requirements for like phd or masters
and i currently for example have a
bachelor's degree
and have like some experience a data
analyst um so just trying to see what
will be like the best
bridge between them having a masters
um to fulfill
um to that like i'm currently trying to
build a github repo very slowly just
because life
but
other suggestions we really appreciate
it and thank you
uh i i mean it sounds to me like you are
already you know your head's in the
right place and you're thinking of the
right things
um i mean
i'll be the i'll be the first one to to
note that like
i don't have a public hub repo um you
know i i could i choose mentorship and
coaching as um the way that i i
contribute so i have a lot of
time for my own projects which is um
i don't know mixed feelings about but um
anyways uh you know i think that um
i think that
it can be very effective though in terms
of like showing what you can do early on
um and and and
getting yourself from the analysts to
the data science position
um
you know there's one like kind of odd
habit that i have um at least i think
it's odd maybe other people won't but
i
have a permanent
job search alert um
in google jobs um you know my what i'm
interested in is experimentation
but um you know you might be interested
in in finance or something different
um
and so you know a couple keywords and i
just have it come to my inbox you know
weekly or some cadence the reason why i
do that is because um it helps me stay
fresh with what's going on around me
uh particularly if i'm not in
conferences or you know if i'm not able
to connect with um
data scientists outside my company it
just keeps helps me keep a finger on the
pulse of what's going on in the industry
in terms of skills people are looking
for
the way that
data science is kind of starting to form
into different subspecialties
um
and the reason why i'm recommending that
is because of that skills-based focus
when you start looking at a lot of job
descriptions you start to pick up on
those patterns and so
you'll start to pick up on what kind of
a data scientist you want to be based on
what you like to do but you also need a
better sense of what kind of skills
they're looking for and where you really
need to focus in on
i don't know if that's helpful
no i appreciate that it's always good to
hear different points of view because
you're going to miss something like i
was reading a lot from the chat i was
like a lot of people had great
suggestions too so
it's good
thanks everyone jenny i see you have
your hand raised you want to jump in
um sure thanks um this is about
resume review kind of you know mentoring
slash resume review so yesterday
uh you know we do we have a couple of
open open positions at our company in
data science and analytics which i will
i will share but
um i got forwarded a resume by a friend
of a friend saying is this person
qualified for one of the roles i'm
seeing and so i
i looked over the resume and noticed
immediately
you know she had
listed
the bullet points under each of her job
titles
she was listing
them
in a sending order of importance or
impressiveness so the things that were
most impressive she was putting last and
she was also
in some of her bullet points she was
sort of being really deferential to her
colleagues like you know i've been
working under my mentor to do this or
and then i looked at her linkedin page
and saw
there were a bunch of
accomplishments and job responsibilities
that were really impressive that were
listed on her linkedin page and that
hadn't made it onto her resume
so
my answer was you know
i'm not sure whether or not she's
qualified for this job but forget about
that she really needs to overhaul her
resume it's not
showing how great she is
and i gave you know specific advice
which apparently she really
appreciated but you know it really hit
me
um
what's the like what's a mechanism for
this i mean it just so happened that
someone forwarded me the resume and i
was nice enough to take 10 minutes to do
this
but not everyone is going to do that and
is there does anyone know of like a
forum does
our studio have a forum for this does
our ladies have a forum for this
um because especially for people who are
very uncomfortable with self-promotion
um it just the resume just reeked of
that and i felt horrible
um
yeah she was just really you know really
uh
shooting herself in the foot and i'm
sure it's really common
i'm not going to lie i was there
myself when i first um when i first
started looking for a job before grad
school
um yeah i just i didn't i just didn't
get it you know like i it's
it's it's funny to me now i will share
with people my very first resume that i
was using
and and i show them like where i started
i show them kind of somewhere in the
middle where i was looking for an
internship and then i show them where i
am now you know and how it's evolved
over time
um but
you know like my thought process when i
first graduated was like well i have a
degree in physics
what else do you want to know
i i can i can i could do anything right
you know it was just so
youthfully arrogant but um
but
you know like
you gotta like i i take the time because
i'm a sucker and i don't say no and you
know i'll i'll help people like you need
to make it easy for people to connect
the dots because that was not obvious to
me before i thought everybody could just
connect the dots
um
and they were in my head or something
like that
but like what what it is to me is
indicative of someone who you know
probably doesn't have a lot of
confidence and it's probably
not in a good um when i see a resume
like that and then the the the
difference
like
that probably tells me they're just not
in good culture they probably have never
experienced good work culture
um
and
i absolutely want to have a conversation
with them and learn more about them
see how they sell themselves um
but in terms of like approaching the
wider problem i i really love um maybe
our lady supporting resume reviews as
part of
[Music]
some of the chapters if that's something
they're interested in
um
you can always tweet at them
ideas i'm sure they're open to it i'm
not
organizing right now um otherwise i take
it there
um there are a lot of
preparation um
companies coming up but
you know at the end of the day it comes
down to people who can afford them
um which doesn't feel great
um so you know i think that
maybe just
we all take a vow to lead by example and
um you know
make a call to action on our own
networks like
are you are you actively mentoring
because you should be you know it's our
responsibility to bring up the data
scientists of the future
and so um we all gotta chip in on that
when we can
yeah i i did post about this on the our
ladies new york city chapter slack
um you know haven't heard anything back
but i'm guessing the answer is that's a
great idea jenny why don't you organize
that
like i know i know that's the answer
you know yeah
yeah
i think that's something that
we could probably look to look into too
as part of the
data science hangout website or
we'll we'll chat more about that
internally and jenny maybe i can reach
out to you
to ask for
some more information too
um i'll also
put that into the linkedin group too and
we can continue the discussion about
that there as well
but along with our ladies maybe also the
r for data science online learning
community slack
would be a good place to do that too
sour is going by super fast
um
i just want to make sure there aren't
questions that i've missed because i see
justin you had put one into the chat
with a star for me to read
so the question was as someone new to
this discipline can you speak about the
intersection of social science and data
science i'm especially interested in
understanding which analysis might be
most useful to learn as my company's
survey guy
slash milton from office space
that's funny um
surveys are great to know
because i think you know um when you're
talking about the intersection of social
science and data science
um you start working with
uh ux researchers so the user experience
um
and there are a lot of companies that
actually um
really double down on mixed methods
research so you have a data scientist
working with a product manager
a designer and a software development
team and
they're a little squad and they they
chip away at their corner of the
universe
um for example i know spotify is is one
such organization
um
[Music]
and anybody who is looking to learn more
about
uh mixed methods research um
centerstat.org
is um
is a small
um statistical
group that does stats workshops and the
quality is amazing um so i know they
have a course available um highly
recommended i haven't taken it yet but i
plan on it
um
network analysis is another one
um i don't think it's used much right
it's not commonly used but
i can see
more and more usage for network analysis
in data science
um it's one of those things where and
you'll see this in some of the courses
because they also have a network
analysis course on center stat um i'm
affiliated with them in no way i just
really do love their classes
um but
uh yeah it's it's kind of
the statistics question of uh how do you
how do you want to model your data do
you want to understand it and network
science network analysis is
is really an a powerful dimension in
that regard
um
[Music]
but i think there's there's also just
like a lot of value in having
data scientists who understand
or even just thoughtful about the people
part of things
all right
that makes sense
i appreciate it thank you you're welcome
thanks justin thanks christy i am
i'm scrolling through to see
questions from earlier but just want to
say if anybody is still on and had a
question that i didn't see
please feel free to unmute yourself or
raise your hand here and and jump in too
hi yeah i have a quick question
sorry i'm i'm outside
um i only logged in about half an hour
ago now i'm great to listen one of the
things i've been trying to figure out is
how to benchmark your skill sets
um so i've just finished a phd in
neuroscience
dealt with lumber you know a lot you
know
very classical
kind of phd to data science but i just
struggle with kind of figuring out how
competent i am or i'm not
you know i don't know if you have any
could speak to that a little bit
thank you
you're welcome that's a good question
i don't
i don't know what this says about me but
i've never asked myself that question
um i don't know i mean
um
like i think that maybe i can just like
you know like like sorry um
yeah
without say just like you know without
just listing like
do you know these packages have you
applied you know have you applied these
kind of methods to these cut like
that is one way i think to kind of do it
i was just wondering if there is a
better way to kind of
figure out where you lie in the
hierarchy of competence in a sense
without that being a
negative way just in ways like a
my
six months of training away or actually
am i like a mid-level data scientist but
just don't know the right labels outside
of my niche
yeah
yeah you know again like
i i kind of um
i don't want to say
that you're wrong um so i don't want to
say that this is like a wrong way to
think about things but
i i kind of want to encourage you to
think about it a little differently um
in the sense that um
like
if if if you're always measuring in
absolutes where you are
um
you're
you're just gonna be chasing a a moving
target forever that goal post is is
going to keep moving
there's going to be more and more and
more and more um i mean even just from
the perspective of the technology front
um when i started we were in hadoop and
i still have to like learn the aws
ecosystem now and by the time i learn
that there will probably be something
else and we're all going to have to
rebuild our data infrastructure again um
if anybody's panicking don't i'm being
exaggerating but yeah so but my point is
is that um i i like to measure myself a
little bit more relatively you know um
so when i when i read technical blogs
i'm not necessarily thinking about my
skill set and like you know if i'm solid
enough in the tidy verse what i'm
thinking about is what problems does my
business need to solve
do we have the skill set to solve those
um
and
um you know
where are we relative to other
comparable companies are they are they
solving the same problems
are they light years ahead of us or like
are are we all kind of like figuring
things out in the dark and making the
same
like similar decisions and and i've
found it's been the latter for the most
part along my journey like going to
conferences and and talking to people
who work in my space i find we all kind
of have the same struggles
and so to me that tells me that as a
team
we're doing all right um
and that is what matters to me a little
bit more
[Music]
um but i i also have just kind of this
like ominous
confidence or
faith i i'm not a faith-driven person in
any way i'm like show me show me proof
but like i do have this faith in that um
you know if i'm doing
i'm doing the things that i like
um
if i'm solving problems
um
that are actually impactful
then i'm doing my job and it doesn't
really matter how many packages i know
that's yeah that's a sorry
that is a that's a really nice answer so
um
that does help it's just you know i
think it's finding the balance between
overconfidence and yeah like okay i
don't know that but i could give me a
week and i can do that versus being
naive
um i think there's something that we can
all just do as data scientists and i i
think it's like we just need to like
we need to stop this toxic like what do
you know attitude
like because that's not what it's about
you know one of one of the data
scientists that i interviewed for
for my new role
she is one of the most well-respected
data scientists in her company
um you know and she comes from a
statistics background
and um i see it repeatedly that
inferential statisticians get judged
differently than
than machine learning data scientists
and it creates all of this like
this conflict and
in this like i said toxicity and
it's it's it's not a contest
um
[Music]
you know we all have complementary
skills we can all learn from each other
um
so let's just do that instead of
complaining about it or you know saying
pitting people against each other
suggesting
one type of data scientist is less than
another
thank you great
answer thank you kirsty
i know where
something really jump in yeah i just
think
uh when interviewing whether for data
science or any roles
like willingness to learn and actually
meaning it like is the biggest thing
above the skills you already know or the
skills you will know it's just that like
you're eager and you
want to be growing into part of the team
um
that was i don't know that's something
that i always
try to get across when i'm interviewing
because i know i don't know everything
at all and i would like to i don't know
grow in the position that when you're
rooting for
that's a great point kate
agreed
i know we are a little bit over here so
i want to see if you had a few more
minutes christy
what do you have to read i don't have a
job right now so
you're like yeah let's talk all day um
i see there was a question anonymous
question i had missed earlier that was
how do you think industry plays a role
in data science higher for example
moving from retail to tech or non-profit
to fintech
um
i mean this is
i don't know
like i i would be curious how other
hiring managers think about this because
this is something that
i've i've definitely um struggled up
against myself uh before i realized that
you know
uh
experimentation is going to be my my
path um
moving forward
um i i did apply for some growth roles
and um
[Music]
thought it'd be interesting because i
really like i said i wanted to connect
to that people piece
but the feedback that i got was they
needed someone with growth experience
um
[Music]
and
i took that again as well they need
someone who can hit the ground running
and that was exactly the feedback that i
got so once they have that first key
like senior hire they can hire people
that maybe have transferable skills
um so
you know when you're when you're when
you're doing that pivot just just keep
that in mind is that you know the team
does
have a specific composition of
experience they're looking for
um and so
um
you know you you might have to work
harder for it but you can get it
um does anyone else though uh have
anything to contribute about
sort of cross-domain data science hiring
i think
uh you made a great point that doesn't
really get talked about enough
is that especially when you're coming
from recruiting you don't know how like
one of the big questions that i ask at
every interview is what's the team
structure you don't know if you're the
first person
uh they're starting bradley team or
second or however big the team is
so i think
that's something that
needs to be taken to account as
even if you're willing to show that
you're you want to learn
for me anyway
i want to make sure there's something
else that i can actually learn from
i don't want to be just learning by
myself i want to have something that's
been there done that
so that's a big part for me
that i think that you briefly touched
upon but i wanted to touch upon more
excellent point so i think from my
experience
the more traditional the industry
i won't say the easier the interview is
but
the less theoretical it's going to be
like if you're
if you and i've interviewed with
fintechs and everything else
and they want to get into this
theoretical game or they think you're
some software engineer that's going to
develop the new recursive algorithm to
solve the traveling salesman problem and
that's what that's what you can have
focused on
um
interviewing banking insurance health
care all these others
it's basic problem solving yeah you go
through a handful of those
stats questions you know can you figure
out the average of you know
some money and or whatever and you know
how would you segment customers going to
a sports game i mean some stuff like
that like those are the how do you think
generic questions but
um
they have and and and same thing i mean
i've been a leader i've seen hundreds of
resumes and done quite a handful of
interviews and
um
none of that stuff matters to me
like
and and i've seen it in a couple
linkedin posts like and and the end of
the day is
if it's on your resume you're going you
should be prepared to be asked about it
rule if i'm number one
um
really thought you know rule of thumb
your resume i mean this is i'm old
school so i transitioned from the
military now we used to always say
your resume should be the 3m principle
men money and machinery how much did you
manage and what did you do with it
job just laundry list of job
descriptions aren't going to get you
anywhere
uh into someone's point on here putting
your least significant thing at the
bottom disaster
um and in fact i'm reviewing somebody
some random person's resume one of my
discord course channels uh and they put
all their courses up on page one and a
page two is all their work experience
and they said to me we're trying to
transition jobs i'm like no one's going
to get you you're not going to get an
offer you're not going to talk to
anybody and here's why
and and so it's you know some things
like that um
but
uh and and i always tell a lot of people
don't look for the entry level data
science job you know it is literally the
one in a million
go for
um
that marketing or that finance or that
ops job somewhere basic where you're
going to show up
maybe they want you to run xl all day
but you know what you can go and run r
all day um and and change the game
um
and i've done that a couple places and
now you have bullets on your resume you
don't have to be there forever the job
you're taking isn't the rest of your
life the job you're taking is i don't
know two years for years um could be
less i mean i've spent one year in many
jobs
um and it goes fast
yeah
there's no benchmark like
i you know one of the things like i
don't believe i don't believe in a
posture syndrome i know people feel it i
don't believe in it because you know
what
there is always somebody that knows way
more than you do down the road so so
stop thinking about that is do you have
the skills and the requisite experience
to the job you're being asked
that's the question
um and that's what you got to answer
and so
you know you didn't get asked to put a
shuttle on the moon
you got asked to solve some basic
business problems
and
you know that's it and you know think of
yourself are you can you do that are you
solving those problems
and does it do you have experience to do
it or can you reach a little bit
um
i mean i've never been fully prepared
for every every job i ever took because
i you know it's one of those you have
some basic set of skills then you get
there you're like oh boy this is a bit
more so you grow a little bit like every
new job should be a stretch and if it's
not
you know maybe looking for the easy one
i don't know um but every new job's that
way
um
and i'm gonna record this as a pep talk
anytime i feel impostor syndrome
we are not impossible we just don't know
know everything um and that's okay
it really is
um
definitely
sloan i i know you had a question
earlier and i can't find it in the chat
because there's so many awesome comments
too if you want to jump in
sure um christy everything that you were
saying about the people aspect of data
science is speaking to me a lot that's
what i love the most about data science
and i also have most of my background in
data science is also experimentation um
but i'm fairly new into my career and i
already know that the people aspect is
where i find the most value and i i'm
starting to do a little bit of
mentorship but
i i'd love to hear more about your path
and how you were able to mentor more
people and maybe some advice that you
would give someone that
knows that that's the path that they
want to go down as well
yeah
um
you know i mean
it
i gotta say like
my my journey has been
um oh i don't want to say you know i
don't want to say just luck because
there's a lot of hard work that went
into it
um but there's also a lot of luck you
know um
i
i got lucky um while i was in grad
school
i won't tell you my full full full
journey because that would take way too
long um we'll just say i went to
i think
13 no nine colleges and universities
over the course of 13 years
and five majors
um so yeah it's complicated but um
but
like when i think about my journey i i
got lucky with um starting at groupon
um because
working there as an intern or a contract
analyst is what it was while i was in
grad school
um allowed me to get in there and and
make some relationships and so when i
did graduate from grad school
i was lucky enough to um to already have
established contacts there so going back
to
i don't remember whose point it was but
the idea that you know those
opportunities can come from from
anywhere
um
i being creative about where you look
for opportunities that internship was a
tableau gig i was a tableau
administrator it was miserable i didn't
like doing it i didn't do it for very
long
but it was the key that got me into my
next job at groupon and i had actually
worked with my hiring manager briefly
and i tell this story to him he knows it
briefly before i left and i remember i
saw the job and it was his job opening
and i was like oh gosh chris
he's kind of weird is what my first
impression of my my future
boss and mentor was
but i decided to do a google search on
him
and um turns out that
he
is someone who really cares about
building teams and uh trust and
communication and all those core tenants
of what makes great teams great um and
that was that's the thing that he is
committed to and so i had a great mentor
right off the bat
um he
fun fact he had say a two
and a two hour commute home like to and
from the office every day he took the
metra in and out and so on the metra
here in chicago he taught himself r
so that he could be a better coach for
me knowing that i was a new grad in my
role
um
and like so that's the kind of boss you
want to find and that's how i got lucky
but part of it was intentional i googled
him and he had an online presence and i
knew that that was his brand and that
was what he was about
um and i got a lot of growth there i
mean he used to joke
half-heartedly that you know he only
knows three things
it's probably like 10 things neither of
us have written them down
but those core tenants that he taught me
um you know about community about uh
about growth about
resolving conflict about um
about you know learning and friction and
building trust those are all things that
i learned from him
um
so again like i said just build
relationships
and the rest
is gravy
definitely thanks chrissy i like zach's
comment then that's not luck then it's
research
fair good job
well if you would have heard my tech
screen you you'd agree with me that it
was luck
i see that people were um commenting
about different titles for data science
jobs and
libby said yeah call me what you wanted
to call me but i had a question someone
had reached out to me
from a large insurance company and they
have this role data science engineer
that people just
they just haven't been finding
candidates for and we were wondering if
it could also be like that title
doesn't come up as much for people in
their job search
yeah
um
[Music]
it's a lot of creativity and titles
right now i thought like we had kind of
landed into settled settled territory
but there's um what we got we've got
data science engineer is a new one to me
i haven't heard that one
um i think another one that's kind of
controversial right now is decision
science
what's the difference between a decision
scientist and a data scientist
um my last title was decision scientist
and i still can't tell you
my guess is that you tend to see
decision science and
logistics a little bit more
they tend to deal with metric soup more
often
um
but
yeah i mean i personally i don't think
titles are important again like i'm
focused on what i'm doing
and so
um
if i'm doing what i want to be doing and
i'm paid a a
fairly um
then that's that's what i'm mostly
concerned about and that i'm growing
that i'm pointed in the direction that i
want to be and then i'm making progress
um
but you know i guess
i would ask myself how is a data science
engineer different from a data scientist
um
and what kind of a candidate are you
trying to attract
uh yeah
i think it maybe could be a mismatch of
the title because i wonder if i think
the role is actually for like
um administrating data science tools for
them
i'm not sure i see
yeah
yeah
that's a tough one
i mean i think that person would
probably be a little bit more if they're
implementing data science tools
or administrating and implementing
um i've seen
them usually as
an analyst or a developer
physician i think
engineer i think
data science and engineer it's like
almost putting two really like
um
not well-defined terms together
making it even less well-defined
yeah maybe nobody's nobody's sure to
apply for it yeah i'm like i'm not what
it
does and i'm not sure what an engineer
does
no but um yeah i think
there's an opportunity to be a little
bit more creative and targeted in there
yeah
definitely
um
okay i'm scrolling through the chat to
see if there are any other questions i
missed just want to put it out there to
everyone to raise your hand if i missed
you i'm sorry if i did
i love this conversation today christy
thank you so much
thank you for having me it's one of my
favorite things to talk about
this is
great okay i'll give people a few more
seconds to jump in with last questions
um but chrissy what's the best way for
people to follow up with you if they
have other questions is it linkedin or
twitter what do you prefer pretty active
on linkedin um one of my goals this year
is to figure out how to use twitter
i've had a few false starts
[Laughter]
we can
i'll share your linkedin through the
data science hangout group but also just
want to remind people that we have that
so if there are certain conversations
that you want to continue
there's the data science hangout
community group on linkedin let me put
that in the chat here again
here we go
you all so much for watching do you have
one thing if that's okay
and it
it's having something in your background
for a zoom interview uh
i've got football show back there and
interview you can talk about five ten
minutes talks about
uh like getting you they'll ask you
about it get you talking about and it
helps you like sort of calm down
so because of course you're it's your
you're at home for zoom interviews you
can sort of help dictate what's in the
background
so
that's something that i found quite
useful
that is magical access a professional
i can talk about plants
aaron i see you had your hand raised too
uh yeah earlier uh when we're talking
about linkedin
um one thing i struggle with is what to
put on linkedin versus what to put on
your resume um mine's kind of a jumbled
mess um so do you have any kind of
guidelines on
on how much you should put on linkedin
versus your resume
yeah um i mean
i think it
probably depends on the depth and
breadth of your background and what you
want to highlight
um
for example i'm i'm not a phd
i don't have a lot of research or
publications to share
so um for me what i showcase
is going to be a little bit different
than what um someone who comes from a
research background might showcase
um but
i would say
i
my linkedin profile
um
is almost
a carbon copy of my resume
just not as updated
um maybe a little bit
more brief no it's the same i think
i don't pay much attention to it as you
can tell
[Laughter]
it's got it has the essential
information
um and
and and then a couple of um maybe
articles that i was featured in where i
talked about the work that i was doing
um
enough context so that somebody
understands what it is that i do
um and and what i have to offer um
for me i just i view my linkedin
um as a way for me to connect with
people that i'm interested in connecting
with but also like as far as i'm
concerned
like it's also just the minimum
information that a recruiter needs to
like
determine whether or not i'm someone
they want to connect with
like that's i see that i see some some
people literally just have a title and
that's it no description and some people
go into like a book for each position so
i just wanted
if you had a
preference
i think that i mean because i have and
this isn't a humble brag it's just
i have a ton of recruiters reach out to
me all of the time
and
um
i think that that is
uh an artifact
largely of my network that i've
developed um
people that i'm connected to the people
that i maintain relationships and my
activity on linkedin
um i think that those things all drive
i mean
my it's not like my first job was at
facebook my first stop was at groupon
you know i mean
there was a moment there where they
almost got de-listed it's
it's not i mean they have a good
reputation for um
for developing good technical people
um but it's it's not a
it's not a huge successful name
um so yeah i i put my effort into my my
personal relationships and my
professional relationships
thank you you're welcome
i do think it's helpful when people like
introduce themselves through linkedin
too and like the little bio that's there
but it's nice that like you can include
i don't know your favorite posts that
will be featured at the top so everybody
sees those too
yeah yeah that's good advice i didn't
know you could do that
i think i spend too much time on
linkedin
um
but yeah but also connecting with people
that are in
like the area that you want to get into
too because i think that if once you
like like their posts or comment on them
other people will see you in that area
too
they'll reach out and connect with you
[Music]
and while we're on the topic of linkedin
um
one other thing that i think is really
helpful is if someone does connect with
you
and to always say like thank you for
connecting and just open the door to
conversation with them because you don't
know why they were coming to your
profile and maybe they don't want to
just like reach out and
ask you a question right away
but at least saying something to them
kind of opens the door to that
awesome well thank you so much christy
for joining us and sharing all your
insights and thank you all for all the
questions too
thank you so much for having me
you